Gary from looking you up online I know
what a big thing for you is not
accepting the word now and and it thank
goodness it seems like a lot of things
have come your way by you continuing to
push forward when should someone
actually accept that word is your is
there a normal time let's define our
terms I'm not sure that one should ever
accept the word no III really mean that
it's in I once gave a talk the title of
which was no is just a conversation
starter and that's really what I believe
it to be when someone says no to me I
haven't done my job it's a clue
I should tell a more persuasive story
take a deeper cut knock on more doors
there's something I'm not doing to get
the yes and they're helping you by
saying you're not there yet
that's exactly how I've you know in the
film industry your life is all about
know you get knows I'm not telling
anyone anything they don't know they've
all experienced this we all experience
at any times it feels very harsh and
personal and and and defeating but I
really don't I don't want to waste my
time feeling blue about people not
lining up behind me it just every every
time I hear and know it just incites me
to push harder and be better and and
speak more crisply and authentically so
you can't say no if I can be undeniable
but that's my job that's all of our job
is is to tell people who we really are
why we really want what we want it's not
just a script for God's sakes this is a
story that needs to be told I'm the only
one who can do it this is why this is
the team I beside whatever it is and so
and my gosh for every film that I've
gotten produced there are so many dead
projects on the floor that ultimately
did die but if I took no for an answer I
never produce a film we've always heard
that a hallmark of a great entrepreneur
is being irritated by the fact that
someone would tell them they can't do
something because it lights a fire now
is there a way to do it without that
negative sort of oh I'll show them or
maybe that's a good thing
I don't think it's negative um I'm a
very stubborn individual and I used to
think that and there were there were
traits that I always thought and that
could be negative but it's not a great
friend of mine a brilliant businessman
long ago very successful taught me that
you need your PhD pigheaded
determination right and it's true well
there's a balance you know because there
there can be if if you're driven that
way I mean you shouldn't want to do a
thing just to make other people wrong
you should want to do it because it's
that important to you you do have to
listen you have to understand the
difference between valuable feedback or
critique and someone who's just not
getting the vision and if you get if you
get I get a lot of nose where I don't
hear the no but I do hear oh my god that
was a great piece of insight that was a
great bit of advice or they so totally
didn't see what I was getting at here I
better tweak that piece so yeah there's
a lot of learning in there but I I don't
I don't think you stay stubborn just to
be stubborn I think it's because you
really believe in something and there
are enough people who also see what you
see that you're not just dreaming Jerry
you've attached so many a-list talent
names to all of your projects for anyone
looking to cast similar names what are
some of the things they need to know
before they reach out to an agent or
manager
well the key of course is what's on the
page right if actors generally
especially stars and their handlers look
at a role first and the story second so
the role has to be really well developed
I spend countless months if not years
revising and working editorially with
with the writer to get the script just
so and I think when you feel that you've
got something that's real
just brilliant that this is a role of a
lifetime now you're ready to go and the
question at that point is how do you
create a cause celeb and and and and and
how do you how do you get to those
actors or their handlers to to market it
effectively to them and I usually try
and round up support on the fringes
right you always want people echoing
your point of view who are closer to
that person one of the things that you
want to do is you want to first of all
you want to really research these actors
and see who's available in who's not
what you don't want you want to avoid to
the greatest extent possible submitting
it to someone where you're going to get
a no because they're unavailable but the
agencies now looked at it now they
already know it's been rejected
technically by one actor so you want to
kind of you know preset the table
knowing that someone's available knowing
that you can afford them so you have to
you have to have sort of a framework and
then I try to engage people that are
that are on their team starting with
assistance I always do that I always get
a champion inside whether it's the
casting directors office the agents
office the manager's office the
publicists office the attorney's office
anybody's office and I find out who's
the friendly warm one and I get them
talking amongst themselves and I tell
them what good is going on over here and
I create this sort of echo and I do that
in a few directions but bottom line the
things going to speak for itself the
script is I they're gonna light people
up and they go oh my god what a great
story what a perfect role for my client
unless you know the actor personally you
are going to deal with all their
handlers right their representatives and
so you really have to be pretty straight
ahead
I am very selective I send them a script
you know once a year is often frequent
for me so I know I'm very selective when
I send something they read it carefully
and then we have a talk when they reject
it if I think they're making a mistake I
won't bite I will go back to the Asian
I'll go back to whoever's the
friendliest in the group and say I think
we need to have a further conversation
in one case that come
passed and I just simply said I refuse
to accept your pass I pass on your pass
and I set up a face-to-face that was my
condition based on our report I'm coming
in for a face-to-face is that okay and
they said of course and in the room I
was able to convince them and they
actually turned around their point of
view and I got a green light for a forty
two million dollar film see so there's a
level of persistence that's appropriate
but it's based on the nature of the
conversation you know if they see
something that's intriguing but they're
just not up to the two big risk for them
to say yes to put their star in it or
for the company to finance it or whoever
you're going after so you have to know
when to push and when to move on to the
next candidate a common thing you'll
hear when you call one of these agencies
sorry so-and-so does not accept
unsolicited manuscripts how do you just
send it anyway no I know it's actually
one of the it's a real breach of
etiquette to send any screen player
intellectual property that's not
welcomed people generally will return it
unopened or they'll open it and then
realize what it is and be upset it's not
a great way to set the table and that's
for legal reasons right
so I never would submit something unless
they said please send it but if they say
no it's either because they don't know
you and they'll say have a
representative send it in which case you
can have anybody act as your rep it
could be an attorney at a if you don't
have an agent from CAA it's not the end
of the world you can have a lot of
people someone a young manager get a
find a manager Alone's the lone wolf let
them do it
that's the buffer or they may say sign a
release releasing us from liability
because we don't know you and we don't
want to be sued
sign the release your job is to get your
material read do you want people to know
your work to know you as a creator
that's more important so don't worry
about are they going to steal and very
little get stolen
sign the release and send it so Gary you
see so much of the Hollywood fast track
is about relationships very true Ella is
a tough place to read people a lot of
people with hidden agendas how do we
know what it's okay to trust someone how
do they know it's okay to trust us and
you talk about the rule of three but
sometimes you're just in a casual
setting what type of sort of caution or
due diligence should someone do when
forming a partnership a relationship
with someone that they don't really know
that well being they've you know
interact on social media a few times
while the good and the bad there are a
lot of people who profess to know more
or be better connected or have more
seniority than they you know then they
really do but we have Google we have our
ways of researching people and if you
can't find them online
that's a concerning thing right so you
just look them up and and if you listen
carefully and ask the right questions
and I believe asking the right questions
is the key to you know the kingdom
they'll reveal to you who who they claim
to know or have a rapport with and what
they've done and haven't done and so you
can check those things out that's number
one but the flipside of the coin is the
old adage I think it was Charlie
tremendous Jones I forget who said we
are the average of the five people that
were closest to in life so the question
is always how do we continually up our
game ESCO elevate our relationships and
and that's about targeting people that
we want to be an association with that
we want to have rapport with and so yes
it's okay to be on networking
actually socially and going to events
and you know seminars and all that sort
of thing but never in lieu of that very
intentional kind of networking which
says I'm going to target people in each
of these categories representatives
agents managers lawyers producers
casting directors editors cinema time by
the way everybody goes after the same
people producers and agents right well
what about everybody else the senate
agra / sits in the center of the action
on the set that produces the director
the stars all bounded this person during
photography is great he or she has great
relationships and they're sitting at
home like the college professor waiting
for the students to show up and no one
shows up Wow what if I want my script
where advice an award-winning
cinematographer
what if do they have relationships that
could read down to my benefit do they
know the actors that I want to get in
touch with do they know some do they
have representation of course they do
could their agency help me they're not
used to being asked as much as producers
in Asia so I say playbill human
billiards and go to the people who are
least harassed but could be really
helpful and making it the perfect
cinematographer for your film it's not a
big commitment to make so there's a lot
of ways but I say you know would be
careful be conscious be smart use Google
know if someone is legit but at the same
time really spend most of your energy
targeting who you really do want to know
so Kerri we had a question come in via
Twitter from Natalia Gallucci and her
twitter handle is evil artists and a
little Italian by the way so she writes
we have a consider for our script which
tackles gun violence any tips on how to
get
used so what are the ways an unknown
screenwriter can take their scripts and
get the thing well I'm not sure where
that coverage comes from that consider
is you know the first page the of the
coverage the all of the major agencies
all of the major studios as a matter of
practice always always have a script
covered they don't accept a script
unless it goes through the story
department gets covered first before the
executive or agent reads it those
coverages are protected like better than
the gold in Fort Knox they never get
distributed so number one I'd be curious
where that came from but regardless I
mean by the way consider is great
because most of them get passed on in
coverage form right so there's something
good about that story but I wouldn't use
that as a tool
I don't think unless you're willing to
unless you can show it and you can
reveal where it came from and who
created it even if you could I'm not
sure it gets you anywhere right because
everyone has to form their own opinion
but what you can say is I've gotten some
very quality feedback from
tried-and-true script analysts in
Hollywood from this company from that
I'm not at you know going to bother you
to read that but it gives me confidence
to approach you and say the following
we have spent you know we've done seven
revisions we've gotten a lot of great
feedback the you know it's it's we're
reaching out to you because your body of
work your artistic signature is exactly
what we envisioned for this story and we
would really love not you how you're
developing person rated we are so
confident of this we're not going to
tell you is going to make a hundred
million dollars we're not telling us the
person to trilogy we're not going to say
silly things like that but you just
really candid with them and you say you
know you evidence the kinds of positive
feedback that you've had and leave it at
that
in general if there's an unknown
screaming of what are some of the ways
to get their scripts produced you know
not just one that already has
considering well I don't think it really
matters that's a great question I don't
think it really matters that much
whether you're known or unknown I mean
at the end of the day a script ism is a
road map a blueprint for this other
medium called film but but we're all
you're all three of us are equal judges
right we're wired pretty much the same
way emotionally if we're moved by tears
or laughter if we're moved by the script
we're interested if the roles intrigue
us that the characters intrigue us
weren't interested
that goes is that's as trooper and
unknown so the question is access right
it's only about access and the way you
get a film produced is is I think really
less about strategy and more about
creative authenticity the careers that
I've seen jump off the start pad the
fastest are the writers who said I am
going to write what I know what I care
about I'm going to write a bizarrely
unique story the kind of story where
people go oh my god
that's different I'm they're not
mimicking what's done what they think is
commercial what they think people want
to see and they just followed their own
drummer and the careers that I launched
the most successfully were people who
did just that they were so different it
was such a unique voice that people went
oh my god no maybe that script didn't
get produced but they got hired for
something else where it was their next
script that got produced but I think the
big thing is is is dare to be different
dare to write the story that actors are
hungry for that producers haven't read
ten times in the last month just be
different be you and whatever that is
and it doesn't have to be I'm not saying
be in the world of nonfiction don't
write your life story but take the DNA
that the heart the guts the feelings and
put it into your characters make it come
alive make it three-dimensional this is
sort of a vague question Gary but what
are the three
just to get started in Hollywood in
terms of you remember coming from San
Francisco being in LA and you have your
own story about I think you got an
office and you hired a secretary you
wait for the phone to ring but don't do
that okay don't do that right okay
something very nice plan but yeah what
are some of the steps in terms of it
could be as an actor a filmmaker
screenwriter which is coming to
Hollywood from somewhere else it's total
culture shock even coming from the Bay
Area where everything seems free and
free love and wonderful it's so culture
shock there's there's unwritten rules
and what would you tell me ya know I
might draw hit the ground when I first
arrived I'm from San Francisco as night
the day this culture and I really didn't
know anybody I didn't know how to
navigate I didn't know the business
actually I had a neighbor who was
brilliantly successful he became the
chairman and CEO of Columbia Pictures
Television he was at the time running
Norman Lear's company very smart very
funny very brilliant guy and he sent me
into meetings at the highest level of
all the major studios and I wore my
heavy wool San Fransisco suits in the
middle of a hot summer fit Singh and I
showed up and I had no idea what these
people were talking about and we made
nice and I left I thought I am
unemployable I have no idea and what I
did is I don't really recommend this for
people but I joined it an outdoor health
club and I played tennis all day long
pal des all afternoon tennis in the
morning for hours at a time and
everybody who came on the court they
were all in the entertainment business
and I would take them aside after a game
and say tell me about what you do how do
you do it what did the job definitions
I'd have questions where I really needed
the information and eventually they
became friends and they'd introduced me
to other people in it and it just
snowballed my first six months I made a
hundred friends just by being honest
about where I wanted to go I mean you
have to tell the universe what you want
and I said it repeatedly and I tried to
pick people who I thought were smart who
well-mannered who I thought had some
success because if they don't know who
you are at first and you just get
disarmed them you find out right you ask
the right questions and you start to
find out and you use your gut your heart
your your better instrument to say these
people feel real they don't I don't
think they're selling me on something
right I don't know the there's no
perfect formula that's going to work for
everybody it's life it's the life is
very lifelike I mean you know whether
you're an actor screenwriter whatever
you are a filmmaker someone once said to
me is a pretty funny thing and it was
this if you have your laptop and you've
got a few hours to spare and you want to
be productive well you could go to the
local Starbucks and all due respect to
Starbucks you can go to Starbucks or you
could be sitting in the first-class
lounge in LAX in American Airlines first
class lounge at LAX where do you want to
be meeting people so if you want to meet
people who can help you and it's all
about relationship it's all about making
people it you know the old adage is it's
who you know and that's marginally true
but underneath that is the truth which
is who feels that they really know you
and not only know you but like you and
trust you and that's record building
where are you going to find the people
that you want to invest in so that they
come to know like and trust you and will
actually open doors and be helpful for
the right reasons and so I would say you
know there are charities there's events
there's organizations there's places
where people who have been successful
congregate and you have to research that
and it's going to be different maybe for
an actor than a writer and if you're a
writer you're going to call the writers
guild say what kind of mixers do you
have what events do you have and you're
going to go on chatrooms
you find people who are really
successful online and you're gonna
follow them on Twitter and it's the same
thing you're going to retweet them
you're going to acknowledge them you're
going to ask them a question and after a
few months they're going to know your
handle you're going to be familiar and
eventually you know there's so many
different strategies online offline but
again it's been intentionality the thing
that is the dividing line and I'm sorry
to give you such a long answer the
dividing line is this some people are
just perceiving life as random and
mysterious in it and hoping a good thing
comes along and others are saying no I'm
going to go to the first-class lounge
and I'm going to go to
search.twitter.com and find the top
players I'm going to research them on
Google and I'm going to learn where
they're from I'm going to learn so much
information that they're going to think
I was their neighbor growing up that's
cool to me it's about gamifying the
business people are a little intimidated
by it turn it into a game make it fun be
honest about it but don't be intimidated
about cold calling just say how can I
make this really interesting for the
other person how can I add value for the
other person
and just because you're not a produced
writer or or or or actor or whatever it
might be never make the mistake of
believing that you don't have value to
contribute to that other person it may
be you find out that they have a child
who is engaged in something you know
something about it may be that you're
involved with the same charity they care
about it could be a lot of stuff but
there's always emotional currency and
value to be given as a gift if you care
enough Gary I watched a video interview
that he did where he talked about for a
while you were in San Francisco he had
long flowing hair and you're kind of a
lost soul you know and it sounded
actually very romantic and intriguing
what if someone's over 35 over 4
and there's sort of that wanderer that
lost soul and they are having trouble
harnessing these creative ideas because
we know a lot of dreamers you talked
about for a while you were that way or a
dreamer and all these great ideas but
what a lot of dreamers seem to have is
they don't harness those concrete ideas
they don't get them done how do you fix
that is that a matter of discipline you
hit the word I mean there are people who
are dreamers I was a dreamer I went to
law school in part not because I want to
be an attorney because I wanted to learn
an adult language and in discipline at a
framework where I could ground myself
because I really was quite a dreamer and
it worked and I am very disciplined in
my approach to stuff which is you know I
mean it's one of the great paradox who
are at the book flow in the book
creativity who talks about the ten
paradoxes of the creative personality
and one of them is that you are sort of
you know a creative person is all at
once sort of playful and and and
unstructured and at the same time
incredibly disciplined right they are
they live in a fantasy worlds but
they're really done I mean doggedly
attached to rooted in in pragmatic
reality there are all these paradoxes if
someone is purely a dreamer it's going
to be tough right at some point you you
you either get so frustrated that you
say I need a plan and I need to pursue I
need to take troubies course I need to
take McKee's course I need to find some
mentors I need to invest X number of
hours every day every day or they're
just never going to make any progress I
mean that's the truth
they won't so you get out of things what
you put into them we know that we're
taught that and it's true and so it
takes hard work it I bred you know
someone asked me how do you how are you
so fast with story and restructuring
story working with writers and
writing yourself and all that and the
truth is that I was about five years ago
ten years ago I forget and I realized at
that time I said conservatively you know
could you figure out how many scripts
you but I realize it was over ten
thousand scripts not all of which
obviously but a number of which I had
actually given notes on and rewritten
with writers or given notes on revisions
I had put in so many hours they say
master he takes 10,000 hours I don't
know if that's actually mathematically
true for everybody but it's a right idea
the discipline to stay the course and
say you know what I am going to commit
to a daily practice that includes so
much time toward becoming what it
filling black the screenwriter associate
with other screenwriters take courses
write X number of hours a day read
scripts X number of hours I mean just
really live it if it matters that much
to you I hate a in fairness this big
point you talk about someone over 35 or
40 doesn't matter they say that
Hollywood is a just and there's some
truth to that and I say pay no mind who
cares when you submit a script they
don't know what you look like they have
no idea how well do you work they're
reading a creative work that's your
issue right when you show up and they
want to buy it when you show up believe
me if they really have a purpose behind
their decision to buy it they're going
to buy it you can do things
independently there's a lot of ways I
think that people stop themselves but if
they're 35 or 40 in their dreaming and
they've been dreaming for 40 years and
they've never disciplined themselves and
they've never really practiced success
principles it's going to be tough so
your rehab so to speak
Gary's rehab for dreamers would be get
that daily practice associate with other
people of like mine you know
watch material that you want to have
made things like that it's interesting
to me is there's a lot of quote study
groups and there's a lot of networking I
see the lawn but I'm wondering sometimes
how much work is really behind the
scenes you know a lot of people on
social media tweeting and that's all
great but then I'm curious how much
actual work gets done and I think
sometimes those dreamers myself included
I fall into this category get caught up
this of that other stuff and then the
real work doesn't get done I think many
of us would agree that a lot of what we
call networking whether it's through
social media or in-person is is not the
most productive time ever invested that
it can be a wormhole of that really
leads to no great value and I had I had
a very successful business a friend of
mine in real estate every year he comes
up with a new tagline for print for that
year for himself which I thought that's
interesting
so his tagline the other year a year or
two ago was fewer what was the I'm sorry
it's taking me a second fewer bigger
deals you were better people and I
thought wonderful he's really going
against he's swimming upstream right
he's the he's the Sam and he's going
upstream he's the one who's going
against the trend of spending more and
more hours in social media and so on and
so forth and it all happened because he
lost his Blackberry and he lost all the
data and he decided that he only needed
six people that was it was six great
people in your life all of whom
recommitted to helping each other
realize their dream and using the
rolodex for the benefit of everybody in
that circle that was all you ever needed
and he's closed that that that sounds
true to me more than not so I think this
idea of like networking aimlessly to
know superficially to walk home with a
bunch of business cards motive ed I'm
not sure how useful that is my best
results all have always come from being
very specific very intentionally
purposeful in designing who it is that I
want to know going and meeting them
finding anyone who can help me meet
those people and it might be a type of
person or it might be a specific
individual and I just do that repeatedly
so it's not that I'm a social guy I like
meeting people I'm fascinated by people
they Oh everybody has an amazing story I
want to hear it but at the end of the
day in earnest when I'm serious that my
career I can't interact consistently
with a thousand people or even 500
people so I need to find those dozens
max that I can interact with on a
regular basis and go deep as opposed to
having superficial exchanges
you said the Facebook like is maybe not
as because we I think that step is
overrated
I don't I personally have no idea what a
facebook like it's worth I know it's
widely debated and some people think
it's worth something other people don't
it's a sliding scale and that's a
metaphor I mean it's literally true of
that but it's true for all social media
we're questioning all the old standard
institutions Arbitron Nielsen all the
rating systems the quantum CPM model the
advertising agencies the digital
agencies the media companies everybody
is trying to redefine what constitutes a
satisfying outcome how do we measure
that in today's world and that's why
dollars are trying to move up
traditional media into into other realms
and yet we're not really yet sure
exactly how to measure so the transition
is a little bit slower than it than it
might be I don't know the answer you
know I I mean branded entertainment Sall
fascinating phenomenon a huge
opportunity of sandbox for people to
great you know creative people to get
work and do stuff that's that's really
cool
but at the end of the day it's some
experiment right now and I think that's
true for a lot of things that I what
would I say about social media is in
business model I think you have to know
what your help desired outcome is and
use whichever platforms lead you there
most efficiently I believe in being very
efficient with your time I just started
using Instagram I just you know recently
and it's it's it's fabulous the amount
of feedback I get off that the number of
followers and whatnot it's it's really
quite stunning to me I tend to use
Twitter more than I use Facebook now I
find Twitter is more the nature of the
dialog the nature of that community and
the conversation is much more
appropriate to what I want to talk about
where I want to go
Facebook is a little bit sluggish and
it's more emotional and it's more you
know where I want to deal in a world of
ideas and shifts and changes and
opportunities and and creativity and
that's more Twitter for me so I think
you have to know what works for you
speaking of business model which CEO
principles do you try to emulate your
own life or business plan after Wow
great question um there's there's a
bunch of folks that I really admired
they're not all CEOs some of them are
just thought leaders and authors and I
think Seth Godin is Brawley and I think
Malcolm McDowell and Matt Malcolm
Gladwell's burly and I think there's a
lot of really smart folks out there on
the CEO level I have to say it's funny
because I hide it I don't really
appreciate the experience that much but
Howard Schultz at Starbucks one of the
great lines I've ever heard in an
interview was when he said to Charlie
Rose what is the spec going into the
muse
business why are you selling CDs and
Howard Schultz like Emma said our
customers have given us permission to
extend our brand I thought that must be
the single most genius line of CEOs ever
uttered on television and I and I think
that those innovators who say well this
is you know conquer shouts always only
ever been a coffee shop and all they do
is serve coffee that's the function I
don't see the world that way I'm going
to change the rules those are the people
that I like those are the people who are
you know they they just have an
elliptical sort of creative intelligence
that allows them see opportunity where
others aren't seeing and they're doing
things a little bit differently you know
we're seeing it in even in the auto and
things as traditional as the auto
industry Tesla Tesla is an amazing I
drove my first Tesla it was an amazing
experience right oh my god so yeah
there's a lot of people look at it not
for how charismatic they are how or
whether I like their personality whether
I like the sector they're in I like to
see people who cross lines people who
are disruptive in their thought process
we see it a lot in technology you know
certainly I think Steve Jobs is you know
got to be one of those guys for me I
bought my first Apple in 83 I've never
left since you know I've always been
loyal because I think part of the ethos
of that community is we're really
behaving differently because of what
they've created pretty cool pretty big
Gary I heard another video interview
where you said and I think I'm quoting
here pretty woman was a disaster of a
car wreck before we got it made it was
everything it wasn't pretty woman I'm
not picking on pretty woman every film
you know is it's goes down cul-de-sacs
and goes off the rails and burns up in a
disastrous set of flames
every film gets rejected every film the
cast falls apart the financing falls out
the distribution falls out again and
again any the fastest I've ever gotten a
script produced and on screen is three
years and that's considered super fast
many films take a lot longer than that
so you can imagine how many problems the
stakes are really high every film is a
start-up it's a business it's a startup
so you've got the standalone business
model where you say I have the stakes
are massively high because I'm spending
40 20 50 million dollars that doesn't
include the marketing budget for the
opening weekend I'm bringing together
100 200 people who never work together
and they must work together perfectly
beginning day one because I've got
$100,000 a day burn rain you're talking
30 languages you've got bankers and
insurers and bond people you've got
every creative Department to talk to in
their language you've got the music
people you've got everything and you've
got to keep all this flowing quickly and
viewed beautifully in the same direction
and you're going to make this film where
you can get the best way as a trailer
for free and risk everything on an
opening weekend these days this crazy
business model no one should ever fund
these things but they get through
because we have a big appetite for this
because it's powerful so yeah every film
that I've ever produced
died a few deaths and there are many
times that never never never came back
to life
pretty woman actually answer your
question
pretty woman was optioned to a company
that went into bankruptcy and just
before it went into court I grabbed it
in a cash out deal where it would have
been lost forever the next company
option you also couldn't get a finance
inmate overcast Richard Gere passed on
the delma couple of time
before we got it to Disney and they
aren't made him an offer he couldn't
refuse
I had Julia Roberts attached but the
studio didn't want her because she was
not known at the time there was it just
there was one there's an the timing to
make everything meet in the middle is
almost like a miracle when it finally
gets to that point and I think that in a
way I have to sort of Zen or romantic
notion that you have to fail a lot you
have to bump into a lot of walls you
have to really figure out how to get
this right and that when you do you'll
get your film made of the many films
that you've been involved in which one
was your greatest teacher whether they
were good lessons or lessons of regret
they've all been great
every film at been associated with has
taught me a lot and by the way and truth
be told probably learned more from the
films that didn't get me thinking back
on why they didn't get made what could I
have done different but the films that
got made which are the ones people know
a bit more hopefully I would say the
moth Mothman Prophecies which was
another Richard Gere film was the and
there was one moment one seminal moment
and again that was a film that that had
been shocked all over town every company
independent medium big studio all passed
on it I wasn't involved at the time the
agent shopped at the writer I hadn't
produced before I was
I actually got to produce his first film
and he came to me and said would you
read this and I fell in love with it and
his and and then I learned it had been
passed on and I found there was one
company and only one company that hadn't
seen it
that was Lake Shore wonderful company so
I said you know what I will I will
invest time in this and I will take it
to lakeshore and and I knew it was that
was it there was literally one buyer in
the whole world I can sell this to so I
went to them they read it three
executives and they called me the
following Monday morning typical Monday
morning call right brilliant story
we loved the craft it was intriguing
based on a true story oh my god
fascinating a beautiful beautiful
beautiful responses from all of them at
which point one of them said so thanks
so much for sending it over it's going
to be passed only in Hollywood and I
thought that wait a minute I'm sorry did
you just say it's going to be a pass all
this all that all that you you're you
know all this laudatory language and
then you're dead and there was long
pause because I knew this was it this
was the last man standing there was no
other option and that was the company I
mentioned this earlier that was the
company at the moment when I said I
respectfully pass on your past and it
was some nervous laughter I said look of
course you can pass but based on our
relationship and our respect for one
another I would ask that before you make
a final final final decision let me just
come in and talk to you so I I went to
this meeting I told these three
executives the story of my relationship
with my dad why because the script when
I read it initially was so moving to me
because the character played by Richard
Gere is so lost in grief after his
beloved young wife dies and a lot of
what the texture of it were was
reminiscent to me of what I felt after
my dad's death he was my best friend and
and to me this film
was a great film in its own right and it
deserved to get made and more
importantly it would be a private amage
to my dad and so I care deeply about so
I went into this meeting with three
people who'd read it and said nice
things about it but passed on it and so
I thought the door was open just a
little bit and I never referenced the
script I never talked about the title I
just simply told the story of my dad I
told who my dad was I talking about our
friendship and our relationship and the
love that we had and what it was like
when unexpectedly never having them sick
he just passed away what that was to my
family and to me and I just spent not
long 12 minutes 10 minutes telling the
story at the end of which I simply said
I cannot imagine any one filmmaker actor
audience doesn't matter who will not be
moved where why whether we lost someone
or not were wired to understand the
tragedy and despair of losing someone so
close to you and they huddled and they
changed their mind bottom line they
changed their mind and we got to make
this film and it's a great film it
wasn't as big as pretty woman but but it
was well-received in acts I become more
popular over over over the years and I'm
very proud of the film but in a way as a
learning lesson is like you know we
talked earlier about never take no for
an answer
and I think what I came away from that
was if you are you know if you're ballsy
enough if you're bold and courageous
enough just it's like get naked in
public if you're willing to get naked in
public people are impressed right
because we all know about vibration and
frequency and when if you're like you
know when you're deeply moved and you're
in that very deeply authentic place and
there's no BS we know it it's real
that's very attractive to us and that's
what we want to put on a big screen and
that's what they got they got why this
is going to move the audience and
therefore potentially be a success and
the film was successful as a business
matter but I that's now you know it I
don't measure it in those terms I just
think how do I get a yes from these
people so I can do what I so desperately
want to do as a creative person and and
the only thing I could do is tell the
truth and it worked
garyun case why you turned to
Kickstarter to sell publish your book
why not get one more traditional it was
a process actually it was it was it was
an educational learning curve for me it
took me a while to figure out that I
didn't want to publish her that I did
want to self publish and the relevant
reason primarily is I really wanted
manifest destiny I'm going to own my own
intellectual property and not give it up
and not be on a royalty basis with a
publisher who wasn't going to market it
anyway I thought you know what I really
would be cuz I care deeply about what's
in the book it represents 25 years of my
life
and I've always been in love with the
storytellers with the creatives and I
want to get this information out so I
thought if I own it I'm more free to do
that in more innovative ways so number
one I thought I'm gonna self-published
the second step was then how do you self
publish it's a very fast shifting
landscape this world of publishing it's
everyday it's changing by the hour and I
thought of and I thought okay I've
decided some things that are good for me
and there's a lot of moving parts so I
thought
okay I'm going to hire layout designers
and people to e format it and book cover
design it and I'm going to hire a
printer and order a certain book run and
on and on it there's a long laundry list
right I thought you know what if I do
all that that's great I'll have a
beautiful book and no audience and I
have to start from zero then I just then
I thought I started these conversations
asking people about crowdsourcing
crowdfunding in particular about
IndieGoGo about Kickstarter and I
realized Kickstarter really was a
phenomenal opportunity not just because
in and--and--and the least of it was the
fundraising what was most interesting to
me was I get this period of time over
which to build a community I get to find
my brand evangelist I get to really put
my message out almost serialize it right
over time and drive traffic from all
quarters from traditional media and my
data base and other people to this place
called Kickstarter it's very dynamic so
this to me was the perfect community
building opportunity precede pre you
know just tilled the soil how much
pre-planning did you do before you
launched the campaign and what sources
did you go to to gather information on
crowdfunding well I have a my my partner
Morgan is a very astute about social
strategy so she knew a fair amount about
it to begin with I did not I had to sort
of study from the beginning and but she
brought me up to speak fairly quickly
and then we just asked a lot of people
who we'd seen doing it that we we had
contacts too and you just Google and you
you know today how do you learn you
google and you ask people and you get on
social media ask people but it became
very clear that Kickstarter was the
platform that was the best fit for us
and and I'll be honest with you you know
it's not quite as neat and clean as you
would hope you use your best judgment
you go with your gut because I think
your gut is your best guide for this
kind of a social experience it's not a
sells job you can't you just it's got to
be about something bigger than that so
it felt like if we just stay if we're
really vulnerable and honest and candid
and and committed to what we're doing
and put that message out whether it's
the video or the copy or however we
present our choice of our ways of saying
thank you the perks that we put together
the people that we enrolled from my film
industry community to be a part of that
if we created that as the ethos the
fabric of who we are and what we're
doing we stayed true to that how bad
could we fail so that's how we began was
just sort of seeded the pants and we've
learned so much every week and it's only
been two weeks into the campaign we've
learned so much well it looks like what
you're almost 80% funded we're weird
we're just 90 percent funded and we're
about halfway through and now we just
did a Twitter tweet of thon today and
we're getting some traditional media to
drive traffic to it over the coming 10
days or week and I think we're learning
how to not sustain energy but actually
build it and create a bigger
conversation and bring more invite more
people in and what's interesting is how
much people are ready to say yes people
really like to be part of this kind of
open conversation about something they
deeply care about and not they don't
deeply care about it because it's
necessarily screenwriting and they're
not a screenwriter it's about creativity
it's about seeing people realize in this
case maybe it's even seeing me realize a
dream of mine there's something that
really tugs at people about that and
it's cool Gary your book that you have
on Kickstarter right now
campaign the writers guide to Hollywood
was that your idea or did a colleague
suggests it to know is my idea really
evolved organically because before I was
producing films I was managing down I
was a literary manager writers writer
directors directors and I was new so I
had to not only watch their careers but
I had to launch my own and I didn't even
consciously become aware until much
later that I narrowed it down and carved
out very specific strategies long
structure and then I collaborated with
young writers all the years I was
producing most of those films are
written by first-timers over the years
people come and say how do you get break
in how do you get access how do you what
what do I do their ruins of it there's a
pathway for everybody except creative
people right if you want to become a
financial planner or almost anything
there's a pathway you get this school
and you take an exam and you get a
certificate and you join the mothership
and you go right that doesn't exist for
creatives so I realized that I started
counseling people and then I started
teaching teleseminars which I did like
because you can only get the information
out to some dozens of people at a time
you couldn't reach a big group and there
are a lot of people who not this
information so I thought out of
self-interest and out of trying to help
more people I would just discipline
myself and finally I sat down and wrote
the book of these strategies
that's how so it sounds like you'd
already begun the structure of the book
a long time ago because you'd sort of
hone
about what it takes is that true or did
you sit down and night you just it all
poured out it was hardly one night
hahaha wish now these is the book is a
distillation of all the practices that I
use as a manager and as a producer
because it's really about and and then I
started writing and it took me about it
took me almost a year to write the first
rough draft of the manuscript and to
figure out how to order it and make it
really simple so that people can
actually pick it up read it and say I
got what's in that chapter and I know
tomorrow how to put it into practice
what's the one takeaway we tell us right
now I'm sure there's many things but one
of the sort of a teaser tip that you
could give that's in the book if some
person there are so many I would say to
begin with my mantra is relationships
trunk results and oftentimes you see
especially screenwriters they have been
taught wrong I believe they've been
taught to send out query letters that
are kind of standard letters impersonal
letters to people they've never had a
rapport in hopes that someone's going to
request their script Reeta discover them
and say yes and while in the eighties
that might have worked a bit better it
doesn't work so well today and most
writers will you know say no that's not
been successful as a strategy so one of
the key things in my book is how to make
it fun how to gamify how to be
successful and really getting in those
doors through the telephone in a way
that doesn't put the onus on the person
on the other end of the phone doesn't
make them do too much for you too soon
in the airport build a phase right
there's the rule of three you make three
points of contact I show you
they had a research and set it up it's
really simple it becomes fun it's like a
game and if you finally realize that
it's you're in control and you're equals
it gets a lot easier thinking of the
rule of three and the age of social
media puts someone tweet someone three
times would that be sort of a way or or
is that still sort of putting the onus
on the other person it's it's it is a
strategy and it can work but you can't
tweet three times and ask them on
Twitter or on Facebook or any social
platform to enter into a professional
direct relationship it's too public it's
not appropriate you can build some
rapport there but then you have to echo
that you have to actually pick up the
phone call their office speak to their
assistant introduce yourself as a living
breathing creature with a name and a
face so to speak and make it mutual
create a dialogue create it you have to
have a goodwill ambassador on the other
end of the phone and at that point then
yes you're the context is set and going
back to social media is it alright to
pay say hey look at my project or mine
or is it better to engage this sort of
person of interest with something of
their own you know book or film instead
of having it be about you know uh it's
it's I mean your goal is always
self-interest ultimately right or you
wouldn't be reaching out so the question
is how do you do it at what point in the
relationship building process you do if
you come to me or I come to you and the
very first thing I do is say Carol you
read my my book or my script or whatever
it might be you're an extremely busy
person as we all learn today that's a
that's a real challenge but if I come to
you and I say I would like you to be my
friend first of all I know your body of
work I know who you are I've researched
you by the way you went to the
University of Virginia I'm from Virginia
and Bob and you find some common ground
and you make it fun you're charming you
use some humor you're comfortable and
your honors and you say I'm not have a
previous brighter but I so admire your
body of work here at the three reasons I
chose to call out you would you be
willing to give me four and a half
minutes to be my ho most five minute
mentor I have one question
that I really would appreciate your
response to no one will say no because
that's very flattering it's honoring
their wisdom and it's very friendly the
quantum of work is over the second they
finish their answer the second time ask
maybe their advice seek their counsel
about whatever it might be certain kinds
of projects in theory right or what do
you look for when you're looking for an
entertainment attorney to represent a
young writer what we need to write
questions for me to assess how good they
are whether it's good match you can ask
them make up any question you want as
long as it's relevant and let them again
that's a second time right and you've
already spoken to their assistant a
couple of times first you always build
that bridge first never rush through the
assistant we want to honor them because
they're overworked dogged ly tired they
have a rough life they're underpaid
they're underappreciated
if you come to them and show them
respect first they're going to what
speak well of you to the boss and the
boss listens to the assistant they
always I do you you've invested there
you pulled that person out of all the
competition to be your person face of
your arms voicing your own
so I try and enroll that person the same
way a couple of conversations keep it
really short two minutes is this a good
time to come back next Tuesday at one
o'clock when your boss is at lunch can
you spend a couple of minutes with them
you research them and get a couple of
questions in mind many of you calculate
to the boss and your patient because
what you're building our relationships
not going for the brass ring each time
so yeah when I get to you I ask you
questions and the rule of three for me
is the first time we're strangers to one
another the second time we're slightly
familiar by the third time it's oh
that's Karen right now I can begin to
walk over that bridge but again ask
advice honor them make them your mentor
draw them when you ask a question our
brains are wired very predictably you
take a step toward you you need to come
up with the answer it's just where we
are that brings you closer to me because
I'm not asking it so when it does come
time I'd rather give you say you know
what I have a script that I've really
polished I believe and some feedback
that I've gotten you show that you're
professional I've gotten some field one
script analyst to produce writers and
you know my hand Mary
and they've all said it really is
well-structured the characters are in
engrossing whatever you say that said
they're not you I would love your
opinion however I don't want to ask your
state to our secret identity I will send
you the first 15 pages if I haven't
garnered grabbed your interest by then
all bets are off right if I do then
you'll ask me for the balance is that
fair and all I want is some feedback
that's it five minutes maximum because
it will take them what less than ten
minutes to read 15 pages of a screenplay
and even spend a few minutes on the
phone with you so you're very mindful to
ask for very very small Quantum's of
work even after you've had your third
interaction you build it's like any
relationship